gay gay gay everything each week there
is some breaking gay news and we've got
some good gay news here Nike wants to
sponsor an openly gay athlete so Rick
welts who is currently the president of
the Golden State Warriors he's openly
gay and he was the president of the
phoenix suns when he came out this is a
couple years ago and before he actually
came out he met with NBA commissioner
David Stern some executives at Nike and
the nike people told him that if an
athlete comes out they would like to
sponsor that person and now he's just
waiting for somebody to do this and I
think this brings up a lot of questions
but first seems all good right that Nike
is throwing it out there just putting it
out there before someone's even out we
want to give you money hey even if I
well if I weren't gay nothing good out
right I don't think you are gay no but
if you're in a traditional marriage as
far as I'm I am yeah what I'm saying is
if there's an athlete who's not gay yeah
what I read was that there's millions of
dollars for this person so they could
just fake it for okay hey you're saying
they could literally be gay for pay as a
term in gay porn right you're saying is
bullets now it's in sports they could be
gay first there is a straight guy out
there that's going I want some of that
cash I don't really need thinking how
funny that would be yeah sure you're not
the only person who's thought that
there's someone in the locker room who
is questioning that yeah I wish it were
adidas they were sponsoring them because
I prefer dias yeah but you're also not a
professional no not anymore retired but
with adidas as a sponsor um I I mean
it's great it's more incentive I guess
to know I guess maybe push someone out
but I don't know that that's the right
term because I don't know that that's
fair yeah it's good to know that there
are people that are willing to rally in
support but i don't know maybe that is
my point is it gonna for someone too
much too yeah the first one to sign on
the line they're adults right yeah
there's something that seems a little
bizarre about it to me to dangle the
money out there first because if nike
for example they use
take the cream of the crop they take
Michael Jordan and Kobe Bryant and you
know the best of the best and now
they're like if you're gay right exactly
during it you did it with a dude like we
got millions of dollars for you but you
may be scoring two points a game it
actually seems a little a little bad I
could actually see that causing
resentment against the gay athletes is
that does that make sense yes yeah but
if they had sponsored billie jean king
or Martina Navratilova yeah instead of I
guess they lost money because they were
because they were out yeah they were out
of the sport yeah Martina had said that
she lost she thinks what could have been
about 10 million dollars by being out
but that actually brings up tying which
is that for some reason we accept women
as gay athletes very easily actually
just this week the NBA draft the WNBA
Draft Brittney Griner was selected
number one and came out pretty much at
the same day but Nikes not going to
throw her extra money for being gay
because we kind of do do we accept it
though if Martina lost all that money
and you can see that I mean her career
suffered after that a little bit her
endorsements did do we really accept it
now we're looking for like a male
superstar in quotes to come out and do
that I think one order already did an
episode about trying to keep the privacy
of one of the gay athletes like they
were ahead of the times yeah daddy
tonight can cut that out yeah murder
involved even though there was a murder
okay yeah maybe you're just making up a
show all together it's really
interesting because I had never heard of
this being an issue yeah um that anybody
cared but I guess it's a big deal for a
gay football player to come out it would
be a big I mean there's been no
professional athlete in the united
states that while playing right in any
of the major sports has come out a
couple people have come out after but
you know this was also making making me
think that there are other businesses
still and other careers that being out
especially as a guy is not the thing to
you and one of those such careers
actually is comedy if you're if you're a
girl in comedy or a woman girl woman
lady any of those things the opposite
being a bit yeah the opposite of guy
yeah you can be gay and in a way it
almost works your advantage between
Ellen and Rosie Rwanda and there's
there's a slew of lesbian comedians but
really no openly gay guys where do you
think that come you know we're expecting
an athlete to do it who has to get naked
in a locker room well maybe the
incentive is maybe nike better step up
to the plate and now all right I want
some of that cash two questions about
the first one is back to the sports
thing uh I wonder how much this money is
gonna motivate somebody more than
actually like doing it for one some sort
of reason to be a role model right
someone's throwing a hundred million
dollars at you you're gonna change your
mind a little quicker yeah would that
matter even though in the long term does
that even matter if they did it for the
money to actually we're gay and came and
ended up being I don't know I mean I'm
just looking at it in a deeper way that
maybe i should but or maybe everyone
else should look like that way too but i
think nike is probably going well we had
tiger woods and we had who are the two
others that were scandal at where i
dismantle its arms arms drunk right like
well they didn't turn out so great right
yeah maybe yeah we have nothing to lose
yeah well and just do it like nike just
do it that when they come out with a
commercial that's talking about being in
the closet and then coming out just do
is I mean you general ad campaign well
you were right from the segment before
you found you his new skill at Wendy
Liebman nike if you want to get her
advertising cash bonobos calm is the
official outfitter of the Ruben report
use code trr 20 for twenty percent off
your first purchase